any time i'm like this i'm actually the
aggressor not the receiver
if i'm here
now because i'm trying to
you can't have two hats you can't say or
move you have to be aggressive now
because you'll never actually know
your body memory will never know whether
it's
oh i have to play the bad guy you should
always be
doing aikido so this morning i was
saying about this
we should have both been what we call a
samurai
in this middle position so there should
be no
person who is the enemy
what makes the enemy is the first person
to go
first person and then we find out who's
the enemy the minute you start going
and he's calm he knows who's the enemy
if we both are like that then
we're both aggressive so that's not
ikido there's no sense of
love and harmony that's pretty much
never there is it on the mountain
but it's kill or be killed
right so he skis
i come off the line
and ski i open he moves himself around
here
again it's not
it's
it's a gathering because i needed to
scream
and you have to be careful you don't get
like this you don't have to go
on that with the thing all you do is end
up with what color
a jab with no benefit
i then i couldn't move but i don't move
i do this and depending on how tall i am
he'll choose to either go under this arm
or if he was taller than me he would
come over
that
if he's higher
i can't do that so i i do
the one you've been doing
so this will depend for your if you're
not feeling even
you're seeing even yourself it depends
who you're training with
so so you should have
encyclopedia in your head of knowing
okay it's this one
do you know the practice
i know i know
hey
if if he opens
and i move and i then do this to me it's
sloppy
it's not marshall when he opens that's
all the time i've got
so i can't decide to make i can't choose
my move i can't choose
to go over here i only had
whatever he makes
and that's it so
when he moves again so i'm trying to
make this
right so it keeps it harsh when it keeps
it tight
fades off
you